okay so this is my foundation now i want
to build on it to get to remember this
is my destination this is where i want
to arrive
okay so when you have a look at it what
is and there are multiple choices here
but what do you think is the most
obvious thing you could do that could
immediately get
this to look a little more like this
is there anything obvious and simple
that
you could do emmanuel what would you
like to suggest
okay fantastic so just in case you uh
didn't catch that right
what emanuel is focusing on here is the
left hand side which is smart right you
know we do trigonometric identities and
we're like prove
this equals this and you instinctively
say which one is the messier one
right which one's harder and then i'll
simplify from there over to the other
side
in this you're trying to do kind of
opposite you're like which side is
simpler to work with
so that i can get it to the thing that i
want and clearly this to get to the
left-hand side i want
all i need to do is multiply by two
index laws yeah okay so let's go ahead
and do that
if i multiply the left-hand side by two
bam i'm there so of course positive
integer
or positive real number rather i can
just multiply the right hand side by 2
and everything is fine
so i've got this oops what am i doing
wrong wrong right hand side that i'm
multiplying by it's just a k squared
ok wonderful my left hand side i can now
promptly
ignore it it's in exactly the state that
i want so now i'm going to exclusively
play
with the right hand side i'm going to
look at that and think
okay true but now what do i do with it
remember i said to
on tuesday one of the tricky things with
inequalities is they aren't equal
right so you this this
obviously does not equal k plus 1 or
squared right what does that equal by
the way
k squared plus 2k plus 1.
k squared plus 2k plus 1. i've got that
sort of in the back of my brain i
wouldn't normally write this
because in my brain i'm quite happy with
that binomial expansion but let's just
for the sake of it let's just jot that
down so there's one less thing occupying
our prefrontal cortex
this is kind of what i want to get to
sort of and then you're like oh wait a
second this is
well i can at least see part of that in
here right
look i've got 2k squared here and i need
at least one of them
right so i'm going to write something
which i know is going to seem very
trivial but just go with me for a second
i'm going to write that this is greater
than k squared
plus k squared okay with that
now i know you're looking at that and
thinking um
mr wu this is extension two why are we
just
like breaking things this this is like
this is the opposite of what we were
told you to do in year seven we were
like collecting like terms right
what can i do with this and i'll admit
it's not obvious
so what was that other you remember i
gave you two questions at the start of
this i said watch out it's an inequality
be careful what was the other question i
gave you i even highlighted it on the
board
say it again yeah you louder so everyone
can hear n is greater
n is greater than four this is crucial
right
i need to make use of this fact and at
the moment i'm just kind of doing
generic algebra that doesn't care about
this at all right
uh i've stated since n is greater than
four k is also going to be greater than
four
so i'm gonna do is i'm just gonna hit
pause on this
i'm just gonna name this inequality i
will return to it in a second
and i'm gonna see if here it is i'm
gonna see if this
can lend me some insights with this
okay so i say k
is greater than four all right what can
i do with this
well i'm trying to get to say see this k
squared is looking good right i've got
that k squared at the front so again i'm
having this mentality of
oh the left hand side is good don't
touch it this k squared is good
don't touch it right now i've got to
work somehow with this
and form some sort of relationship with
this do you see that
two k plus one over there i want you to
again
think back to tuesday we're trying to
combine inductions in inequality which
is quite tricky
right if i can prove
that this is bigger than this
let me say that one more time if i can
prove that k squared is bigger than 2 k
plus 1
i can link together some inequalities
here does this make sense
if i can say this is i haven't proved
this yet but if i can say
that it's bigger than whoopsie does he k
squared plus
2k plus 1 right if i can establish that
relationship then
2k plus 2 to the k plus 1 must be bigger
than this thing right you can see how my
inner core is linked together okay so if
i can get to that
which is just to do with two k plus one
and k squared
then i'm kind of there right so you kind
of have to have in your head like ah i'm
trying to solve this problem but it's
creating new problems underneath that
so just forget about the original one
for a second that's what i'm doing here
by just hitting pause on it
and let's try and focus in on the part
that now is revealed okay
so i'm going to say two things number
one uh
let's go here k squared that's what i've
got to work with
here right if i've got this statement
about k
being bigger than four what can you tell
me about k squared
there's at least a couple of different
things you could tell me about it
any takers
it's it's less than two to the k because
i've got my assumption there
that's great but i am going to start
going in circles here so i'm not using
any new information here right so
true but i will put it to one side for
now uh if k is bigger than four
so like case five six seven eight nine
ten et cetera can you tell me anything
numerically about
k squared it's bigger than 16. bigger
than 16. very good because
k multiplied by k 4 multiplied by 4.
that's true
right now i could write again k
squared's bigger than 16
but does that even though it's a bit
rude of me to sort of do this too but
does that help me does that fact k
squared greater than 16 help me try and
get to here
see what i'm trying to prove k squared
is bigger than this object up here
does 16 help me with that very much the
answer is
not as much as i'd like because i could
say that it's true
but then well this thing has sort of
disappeared right i no longer have k's
in there to play with
so instead of saying k squared is
greater than 16 which is true
i'm going to say that it's bigger than
4k
are you alright with that i just
multiply both sides by k
you shouldn't be you can't just multiply
both sides by k k is a pronun rule these
are inequalities that we're dealing with
right
we know that inequalities have direction
why can i say this i can
but why because it's yeah it's positive
yeah
be so careful with inequalities there's
so many little like potholes you can
walk into right
so i'm multiplying both sides it's why
calvin was right to say
i can multiply them both by four that's
fine
but to multiply by k you've got to be
careful i'm going to say
since k is positive
okay now why is this useful to me this
is going to help me get toward
this thing that i wanted i'm going to
try and play a similar trick to what i
did here do you remember that
i was like oh i got 2k squared i want at
least one of them to just come to the
side
because it's here what can i do to this
thing it's almost an identical trick
in fact what can i do to it that is more
helpful than what's written right now
yeah i'm trying to get to 2k plus 1
right
there's a 2k in there in fact there's
there's two of them right
so i'm going to write 2k plus 2
k now maybe finally like we're almost at
the floor
okay we're finally almost at the bottom
i want that to be a one don't i if i if
i make that a one
i'm i'm i'm there is 2k is that
bigger than one it is but how did you
know
ah k's well k is bigger than zero but
more importantly
if k is equal to zero then this is not
bigger than one is it
right but in fact like the smallest this
can possibly be
is uh it's it's 10
right 2k right so it's 10 is way bigger
than one
right so but how do i say that like
you've now sort of pieced it together in
your mind
how do i actually like provide the logic
for that right
i'd go back up to this line over here
that's what you just rested on k is
bigger than 4.
so that means that 2k is bigger than
8 right so therefore
over here i can say that
is bigger than 2k plus 8. did you see
what i just did
pause on it because actually a lot just
went into that right
i got to this point here where i had a
bit that i wanted and then this other
thing
which i i know it's bigger than one but
how do i prove that right well i went
back to this earlier fact that was part
of my assumption
right k is bigger than four two k is
bigger than eight and so i can
say well i'm going to replace this with
something smaller
this is the smaller side is on the
bigger side so that's why my inequality
flows in that direction
along with me so then next line let's
not have too many inequalities linked
together
i have established the k squared is
bigger than 2k plus 8
but of course that's bigger than what's
the thing that i wanted two k plus one
very
good okay
so what have i got here k squared is
bigger than 2k
plus one
we've gone way off the garden path here
like what we're even proving at the
beginning we've taken quite a distance
so that's why i can now say let's return
let's come back here right
i know that this thing
right here relates to here that's where
i'm putting it
okay so i can say substituting into
remember i hit pause on it right
substituting into one what have i got
let's just write it out as it is
2 to the k plus 1 is bigger than k
squared
plus k squared but i've just said that
one of those k squareds will be bigger
than
2k plus 1. you following so far i know
there's a lot that we're holding in our
brains
k squared plus 2k plus 1.
we're finally coming back out of the
hole okay because now i can factorize
that thing
and i'm pretty much home and hose so
let's write that 2k
2 to the k plus 1. i'll just write that
before i've factorized because i'm
actually doing something here
from this linked inequality i'm going to
a different one
now i'll factorize
and i've run out of space on the bottom
of the board so let's just talk through
what we need to do right this is the k
plus one case
right i've used the assumption i've used
this particular property that that k
and n have to have and i've arrived
at a proof that the k plus one case is
true if the k
case is true so you would conclude you'd
say
therefore true by the principle of
mathematical
induction how is your brain at the
moment
so is it doing all right questions yeah
yeah please um
this method seems more difficult to me
but
i wonder i can i can i can i can do this
thing
exactly in excel so can i just move all
the things
like you have 2 to the power of k plus 1
bigger than k k plus 1 square
just move it to the left hand side and
say it's larger than zero rather than
doing all this stuff yeah okay so right
at the start of this i said
you can do a bunch of different things
right there's a bunch of different ways
to approach this okay
i said on tuesday that one of the
classic ways we go about proving
inequalities is
like use sine positive and negative
right and that generally is
like in other proofs i will do exactly
that right so
as an idea i'm okay with that the
particular thing you just said
the particular thing you just said
you absolutely cannot say and i want to
wonder if you guys can help me work out
why suppose i'm like okay this is what
i'm trying to prove my next line is i'm
going to begin my proof
and then i write this and you're the
marker this is what i write
if you're the marker you should raise
some red flags
instantly it doesn't matter what's
coming after this why
joe you don't want to have a stab
because we
are required to prove that you have 2k
plus ok plus one greater than
k plus one square and if we did that
step we actually assume this
is true very good did you catch that
right i'm gonna apply some logic to this
thing right i'm gonna start working on
it
but like i'm working on a foundation of
this which i don't actually yet know to
be true
that's my job right now the strategy is
still not overall a bad idea so how
could we
amend this strategy use the basic idea
but not
commit a logical fallacy or add it
morgan
okay i could consider what's the thing
i'm going to consider though
i'd still rather not consider a thing
that i do not know to be true
so this this part here this is the thing
you're going to work on anyway right
you're going to ignore that zero more or
less right
so just just work with that thing
consider the left hand side
take away the right hand side do some
work on it hopefully
you can get there by the way in this
particular example it's a bit of a pain
these two don't like mixing together but
then you're going to use your assumption
at some point like line three or line
four okay
so overall strategy okay but just be
careful about the way
that you do it you want to make sure you
don't end up
assuming what you're trying to prove
this is
a book that mrs lees and i flagged in
your assessment task in your interest
piece right so infinite powers by
stephen strogatz
there's a section in here that i want to
read to you because i hope
it gives you an additional sense of
appreciation and value for why
mathematical induction
matters before i get to this i need to
tell you
why i used to hate mathematical
induction
when i was your age i hated mathematical
induction because i thought
what is the point of this right what is
the point you begin with this thing
you already know it's true like you
wouldn't be doing this question unless
i already knew or some other
mathematician told you
this thing is true and then we make you
jump through these elaborate hoops and
hurt your brain
to prove it even though we already knew
it from the beginning
this is very different to say you know
you guys are very well aware mrs lee's
in a past life with an engineer
engineers all the time have to solve
problems where the the conclusion
we don't know what the conclusion is
that's why we're trying to solve the
problem and then you arrive at something
like oh cool now i can build my bridge
now i know my building will
you know sustain the wind shear forces
because i've done the dot product all
that kind of thing right
so that's nice but here what's the point
of
like going through all this effort to
arrive at something you already
established let me read from stephen
strogatz he says
he's talking about uh isaac newton
and him introducing calculus which is
what the book is about
and newton's really upset with this guy
named you might know him
rene descartes he was it was actually
upset with leibniz as well
newton got argued with everyone he's
just an angry guy
anyway he's attacking dakar and i'll
explain why he's attacking him
in launching his attack newton was
adhering to a
traditional distinction between analysis
and synthesis what are those you've not
heard those phrases
in a mathematical context in analysis
one solves a problem by starting
at the end as if the answer had already
been obtained
and then works back wishfully towards
the beginning
hoping to find a path to the given
assumptions
do you see what's going on here this is
what analysis is like oh if you already
know the answer you can apply some logic
because someone else told you this
should work out and you hope that it
will work in fact
stephen schroeder continues it's what
kids in school think of as working
backward from the answer
to figure out how to get there okay
that's analysis
synthesis goes in the other direction it
starts with the givens and then by
stabbing in the dark
trying things you're somehow supposed to
move forward to a solution
step by logical step and eventually
arrive at the desired result
synthesis tends to be much harder than
analysis
because you don't ever know how you're
going to get to the solution
until you do and this is where it
concludes
the ancient greeks regarded synthesis
that's the second one where
i'm not sure i'm just going to stab in
the dark they regarded synthesis as
carrying more logical force
more persuasive power than analysis
uh synthesis was considered the only way
to prove a result
analysis was a practical way to find the
result
if you wanted a rigorous demonstration
you had to do
synthesis and then it goes back to talk
about archimedes which is the
subject of the first chapter of this
book who he wasn't so great about this
um
proving stuff but he knew intuition to
work out what the answers should be so
archimedes was the kind of person who
came up with this
but then people looked at these results
and they're like yeah but how do you
know you have to actually apply all this
rigorous logic here here's why it
matters right we make you go through all
these hoops
because this is how knowledge progresses
right it would be really hard if i said
to you
hey uh just find out what 2dn's bigger
than
just go for it find out right or prove
that it's bigger than
n squared and i didn't tell you where i
mean in this particular case it's not
that hard graph it off you go
but what if you just didn't know you
really have to stab around
in the dark and often we get there by
methods that are well intuit intuitive
like i think this will get there and
they're not proof they're not rigorous
but this is this is why we make you put
so much effort into proving things that
we actually already know to be true
usually we actually aren't sure but we
apply the logic and if the logic holds
it's water type okay